qui fait des remous internes et externes
quand on parle de baca festival on parle
de monde de beaucoup beaucoup de monde
dès connu des moins connus quel que soit
l'âge le style la catégorie sociale la
profession il n'y a qu'un seul et même
objectif faire la fête jusqu'au bout de
la nuit
ascq ans la bacchanale c'est le rendez
vous du mois d'août c'est génial c'est
par une équipe de martinique des jeunes
entrepreneurs comme moi même et je les
soutiens 200% donc c'est l'événement le
line up et hop et le 4 est génial venu
ici dans l'espace tival à rencontrer les
artistes et didier c'est exceptionnel
c'est comme la coacher la martinique
donc je suis là pour leur donner la
force
et celui que tout le monde attendait
avec impatience c'est lui tout droit
sorti de la jamaïque pop kahn a assuré
le show pendant près d'une heure
non
le jouer au top c'est la bonne ambiance
et un routage ami noté génial on arrive
tôt pour être devant à leurs annonceurs
et l'apparition d'un invité surprise
n'aura laissé aucun festivaliers
indifférents
kalash lieu aussi a mis le feu à la
scène
moi je suis en vacances et la gencive
près de 15000 personnes se sont
rassemblées pour ce premier jour baca
festibal allant pour assurer la sécurité
de tous les agents sont constamment sur
le pied de guerre
en s'engageant sécurisé à jouer ya 15000
personnes âgées donc c'est très
difficile mais nous on aille je tiens à
le remettre aujourd'hui on à la sous
préfecture et l'ars récurrent du nouveau
casque avec la gendarmerie d'auch date
vous l'aurez compris le bac à festes
c'est deux places to be en d'autres
termes il faut absolument y être pour
vivre cette expérience caribéenne unique
en martinique
[Musique]